do you know what makes a real hero it's
not the costumes the gadgets the cool
Powers it's having your own movie
and that has always been my dream
uh what are you doing just giving to
people what they want our movie's not
about Wonder Woman it's about us the
Teen Titans no one wants to see us fool
Wonder Woman inspires people and we do
not uh yes Wonder Woman is great but I
love Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman
narrator guy I'll just do your thing for
the creators of Teen Titans Go
it's about courage Titans Go it's about
action
it's the superhero movie to end all
superhero movies
hopefully
[Applause]
he farted that wasn't a thought that was
just air leaving my butt which is a fart
Teen Titans go to the movies because if
Aquaman can get a movie anyone can
[Music]
I think we lost him
laughs
[Music]
I'm Batman Batman Returns
Batman Forever there is no stopping the
Batman
every superhero is born from a tragic
life-changing event I propose we travel
through time and stop those tragic
events from taking place Robin
this is the excellent plan
let's do some time traveling yo to the
time Cycles
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
ready
then let's go back to the future I mean
the past
engage
[Music]
that's not good at all
honey I'm sorry well pretty much all day
[Music]
hold it right there yeah shooting a baby
into space what kind of people are you
but we have no choice the crystals are
not harmonized the planet is collapsing
I've tried all tonal combinations
you want to save the planet you've got
to play the right music yeah let us show
you how it's done
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes that's how we do it yeah
now let's go stop some more superhero
origins
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
golly thanks for taking me to the movies
in this dangerous neighborhood dad
oh stop you can't go down there that is
Crime Alley you dumb dumb
oh Jess you take a shortcut through
Happy Lane instead
[Music]
[Applause]
we made it we're back in the present and
there are no more superheroes
the tetronium crystal the perfect blood
device
[Music]
foreign stop right there
Deadpool
what I'm not Deadpool I thought Deadpool
was a good guy why does everybody think
I'm Deadpool you got them guns and the
swords yeah well lots of people have
guns and swords okay nah I'm pretty sure
you're Deadpool look into the camera and
say something inappropriate
I am the greatest
most nefarious most ultimate
supervillain in the world has ever seen
I am
coming this summer
they're finally going to make a movie
about me Belford the movie what
they're doing a movie about the butler
before Robin
every other superhero has had their own
movie and it is time for the Teen Titans
to have theirs so they go to Hollywood
to make it happen lights camera and
Magic Jade is a Hollywood director and
she meets the Teen Titans who are
interested in a superhero film it's time
they make one about me I'm afraid of no
I only make movies about real
superheroes
having a movie is the only way to be
seen as a real hero what about an arch
nemesis Slade is the number one enemy of
the Teen Titans I'm the greatest most
ultimate super villain in the world has
ever seen I am Slade
can we say it Slade even saying Slade
makes you scared and in this film he's
looking to dominate the world the whole
world will be under my control and it's
up to the Titans to stop him from that
we're taking you down Titans Go comedy
ensues and it's very silly and very
funny and it's just another big crazy
fart-packed adventure
that wasn't a fart that was just air
leaving my butt which is a fart normally
it's just us doing a myriad of voices
that was amazing what you call comedy
gold ladies and gentlemen but now we get
Will Arnett and Kristen Bell and
Nicholas Cage it's like prom but
thousand times Huger this guy don't know
who he is then I think it's time we tell
it
so Teen Titans Go the series is like the
rainbow and Teen Titans go to the movies
is like the pot of gold at the end of
the rainbow
and as far as it coming out July 27th
that's ideal because it's hot movie
theaters are air-conditioned so I think
you should go many times nine times in
fact that's really all I'm asking
bigger booms bigger villains we're
bigger
just made a movie oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Teen Titans go to the movies all you did
is July 27th coming this summer
[Applause]
they're finally going to make a movie
about me the story of Batman's greatest
allies it's me that must be me and best
friend in the whole world finally
Belford the movie it's time to clean up
this city
that actually does look pretty good
there was a Green Lantern movie but we
don't we don't talk about that it's time
they make one about me I'm afraid of no
I only make movies about real
superheroes
[Applause]
obviously Titans you guys are never
actually doing anything heroic what
about that time we discovered that
[Music]
that wasn't even crime and you didn't
save anything we save Rupal designs
large nemesis
stop right there Deadpool Deadpool what
why does everybody think I'm Deadpool I
thought Deadpool was a good guy by the
way he should be saying that he's not me
okay because I came out like way before
he did nah I'm pretty sure you're
Deadpool I am straight
we can make him our arch nemesis then
they will see that we're worthy of a
movie
I'm not interested in fighting a bunch
of Sidekicks and a half a robot
oh man I'm never letting you fly my body
again
will be under my control
destroy them how big is your army a
hundred thousand oh for the mighty happy
music
watch me watch me watch me we're taking
you down how are you gonna do it what
are you gonna do you're gonna fart on me
you wanna dance off you're gonna annoy
me to death with your waffles
foreign
[Music]